all right before football pod america
gets rolling let's answer some questions
we're going to get right to it shereen
at stafford 2 denver gee i wonder what
this question is going to be will
matthew stafford be traded the broncos
need a new quarterback and have a ton of
young talented weapons vic fangio and
john elway have a playoff mandate next
season and stafford makes the broncos a
playoff team now first of all i don't
know that john elway has a playoff
mandate john elway is not going anywhere
until they resolve the ownership
situation so as long as that lingers
elway is safe
but hey we saw what they did with peyton
manning i'm intrigued by the possibility
that number one matthew stafford is
available in number two he makes a
beeline to denver just like peyton
manning did
eight years ago what it's going to be
actually nine years ago that peyton
manning joined the broncos
uh it's it's the only great move that
john elway has made as gm at the
quarterback position right i mean he
can't draft him he hasn't signed anybody
else that's coming and done it and drew
lock doesn't look like the answer
mike i thought last year i think locke
went 5-0 last year i really thought he
was going to take that next step this
year playing more and he hasn't the only
guy with a lower passer rating than drew
locke
is sam darnold so he's not the answer
and i don't think he's going to be the
answer i think you've seen enough to
know that so i am very intrigued by this
possibility i think it would be the most
sure thing that john elway has gotten
since peyton manning
yeah lack of durability and lack of
effectiveness combined to create a toxic
stew for drew lock i was all in with him
i thought this would be the year it
isn't and you don't get the luxury of
four five six years for it to work
anymore in the nfl especially when
there's plenty of other veteran options
and there are now every year because
teams recognize they can find a young
quarterback and hope that they hit on a
first second round draft pick all right
next one comes from gong show west if
you were the gm building a team and your
only choice is at quarterback were jared
goff and jimmy garoppolo
who would you sign
wow
look here's my concern about garoppolo i
think garoppolo is a better quarterback
but this gets back to the drew lock
conversation you have to stay healthy
and i don't care what excuse or
explanation you have for your various
injuries there's a point where you get
injured so often there's something
missing in you there's a lack of
awareness there's a lack of savvy
there's a a lack of intelligence not to
drop your shoulder and try to be a tough
guy with the defensive back on the
sideline and tear your acl i don't trust
jimmy garoppolo to be on the field for
16 games the year he was hey super bowl
but he's played one full season in his
career that's not good enough to get me
to put faith in him for golf i i just
i'm sorry i don't i hate to be this way
i still don't get it with goth i've
never gotten it with goth he's kind of
gangly
and
uh yeah uncoordinated and he's got that
weird throwing motion and hey he's
making 33 and a half million dollars a
year so you know more power to him
but i just don't get it with god with
garoppolo i at least understand what he
can do when he's healthy so i would i
would take my chances with garoppolo and
i would hire some sort of separate coach
just to get him whether it's through
hypnosis or whatever to try to avoid
getting injured and i guess i would take
my shot with him although i i frankly
would want neither of them to be my
franchise guy
well that's what i was gonna say i think
i'd quit if those were my only two
choices at that point
but i would take jimmy g over golf just
because i think he's a better
quarterback
uh all right let's uh let's cram in
another question or two here before we
go art junior zero will anthony lynn
secure his job with a win against the
chiefs this sunday or is it a conclusion
that he is gone shereen three wins in a
row could finish the season with four in
a row is that enough to save him
well you just look at how many problems
they've had this year mike with clock
management game management strategy you
know
changing things uh and all the blown
leads they've had and i don't know that
that's going to change i mean anthony
lynn was responsible for all of those
things and he didn't fix it this year so
as much as we all love anthony lynn and
i know the organization loves him i
think it's probably time to go at 32 and
31 and 11 and 20 over the last two
seasons
as much as i respect him and personally
like him i i agree with you and when you
have that young franchise quarterback
and justin herbert he put you in a
position where you can be choosy about
who your coach is going to be all right
one more big daddy bustard
who is new england starting quarterback
next year and where is josh mcdaniels
coaching sheree
i think josh mcdaniels is back i don't
think anyone hires him uh and i do think
they have a different quarterback i
don't know who that's going to be but i
don't think he's on their roster right
now and i think we figured out mike what
new england thinks about jarrett stidham
by the fact that he's not starting games
right now for the patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports